hello my name is Alberto and I'm Angela
we come from Crespo in Argentina
we're in Hamburg in northern Germany
we've been told it's a beautiful city
yeah let's explore it together une dos
Ramos let's go
Venetian style how beautiful Sentra now
again
bon Hanseatic architecture and here's a
shot in colonial style
one many memories how terrific there was
a ten like this in my grandmother's
house how pretty
tins for coffee and tea I but give me
how with my grandparents emigrated from
Germany to the river Volga and from the
Volga to Argentina and they certainly
had this kind of tea tin in one of the
few pieces of luggage they had if only
my grandmother could see this go monkey
see another amia well I would I keep
look at this this is Hamburg so
important where the first boats arrive
are quark I tell you where and look at
the old police you can feel its
impressive history
ah it will seal the immigration Museum
we have to visit that because my great
grandparents and grandparents left from
there where it interests me a lot there
is a move to rural
there's South America is there a lotta
morning I have a watch like this from my
grandparents
pinedo deeply attending our work with
these typical fish rolls
thanks a lot and good bye to everyone